the Euro has created new opportunities
for citizens and businesses facilitating
cross-border trade and investment
bringing price stability expanding
business opportunities and making travel
cheaper but the crisis revealed that
closer coordination of economic policy
is needed to complement the euro to
realize its full potential to deliver
jobs growth social fairness and
financial stability closer integration
is needed in four areas and they all
depend on each other an economic union
in which all countries can grow more
prosperous together the financial union
so that banks insurers and financial
markets can better serve the needs of
European citizens and businesses a
fiscal Union to ensure stable and
sustainable public finances and a
political union to ensure Parliament's
have their safe Europe competes with the
rest of the world and our economies are
interdependent
how can we ensure that all countries
implement reforms so all our economies
become more competitive while ensuring
that social protection systems adapt to
new challenges and remain fair and
adequate households and businesses
across Europe need to be served by
strong banks and functional financial
markets how can we integrate our capital
markets increase funding opportunities
for companies and enhance confidence in
all banks regardless of their location
while making sure that the taxpayer does
not end up paying the bill in case of
poor management one country's tax and
spending policies affect the others in
the interest of the euro area as a whole
how can we make our fiscal policy
sustainable and responsive to economic
conditions and ensure everyone abides by
commonly agreed rules for healthy public
finances economic integration also
requires more collective decision-making
and a unified position on the wealth
stage how can we give parliaments our
biggest say and ensure that
internationally the countries of the
euro area speak with one voice a key
report by the five presidents of the
institution's responsible for the euro
sets out a vision to complete Europe's
economic and monetary union some steps
can be implemented quickly others will
take more time by facing up to these
challenges we can ensure that our
currency achieves its full potential
you